[Music]
welcome to another episode
of the random show this is episode
number seven thousand four hundred and
ninety six
sevens it is good to see you my friend
you too thank you it's been too long
when was the last time we actually saw
each other in person
you were in portland it would have been
in portland 100 years ago because it was
uh simultaneous with
a i think it was acro love festival
where you had
hundreds of people just smothering each
other with
body contact one another with body
contacts but that is a pre-covet
activity
yes this is probably a year and a half
ago huh it's been about that long yeah
it's crazy it's
sad yeah it is it's it's wild and what
what uh
i'm reassured to see is you have your
your japanese podcasting robe on and you
seem to have new
eye shadow arm mascara which really
brings out your eyes
it's called it's called five hours of
sleep dude it's called it's called
babies
is what it is well i like it you're
converging with the raccoon gods that
you
upset so long ago by tossing one of
their brethren downstairs for people who
want that security footage you can
search kevin rose raccoon and it'll pop
you're determined to make that like
what's on my grave like what i'm
best known for is the wreck your toss
your wikipedia legacy
i want it in the first paragraph so we
we shared a google spreadsheet that you
created beforehand
of things we might talk about i'm sure
we'll talk about all sorts of stuff
where do you want to start man yeah i
mean we could start with the bitcoin
stuff because you were super
excited about that which is odd because
you're typically not like
the biggest i i've never seen you as
like a hardcore crypto guy
i would definitely not self-described as
a hardcore crypto guy
at all uh i just happened to have this
combination of ignorance and laziness
which
led me to hold on to the bitcoin that i
had
oh so you're stoked that's why i'm like
why is tim so excited about this because
you have a boatload of money right now
well i mean i don't know if it's a
boatload but i've
i've held on to it i mean look anyone
who is holding
just to put a timestamp in this it's
january 8th
2021 bitcoin i believe for the first
time
ever just crossed forty thousand dollars
per bitcoin it was 41 this morning yeah
yeah so anyone who has ever bought
bitcoin
uh to the unexamined or unexamining eye
looks like a complete genius right but
it's not possible that everyone
bought bitcoin for the right reasons or
through the right process but
nonetheless
here we are and it's exciting to watch
even if it may implode and people are
drawing
comparisons and certainly pointing out
the differences between 2017
uh and now where we saw this huge spike
several years ago and then a consequent
crash now
that's happened several times now it's
happened several times and i should also
point out that i
got into crypto in a meaningful way
right before that crash in 2017.
uh so if i had consequently sold all of
it i would have done so at a pretty
massive loss and i was like well
look i'm playing with house money in the
sense that
i can afford to lose whatever i am
putting into crypto
so i'll just hold on to it and
the premise that i used or the set of
assumptions i used to get into crypto
ended up being totally wrong in a lot of
ways
at least in the sense that i was
investing in crypto as a
as a hedge specifically against say a
huge
drop in the stock market
since i had a few different pending
ipos and so on uh with which is like
uber ipo basically yeah exactly and so i
made a
a bunch of very tenuous leaps of faith
in my logic
to look for different ways to to hedge
against the possibility that a market
collapse
could drag uber down with it right so
nothing stock
specific meaning nothing uber specific
in that case
and i mean you literally could have just
hedged the market though at the same
time
yeah i mean look you could there you
could i could have hedged the market
uh i don't know much about shorting or
hedging or anything like that
and uh when i looked at it even in any
cursory way looking at the stuff that's
allowed
no gray hat stuff uh it seemed very
expensive to do it effectively so i
decided to
become involved with crypto also because
if you're in
certain social circles with certain very
smart people
yourself included i mean you've you've
played a lot in the crypto sandbox so i
want to hear from you more than me
it's easy to get intoxicated it's easy
to
kind of walk into this reality
distortion field where you're like
you know the world is going to mad max
for the next 48 hours
and crypto will be all that survives and
i'm not saying that's your argument
but the the point i wanted to make is
that if you look at the timeline
uh so 2017 boom
right the sort of tulip bulb craze of of
crypto at the time sort of tanks or at
least uh bitcoin
and uh this time around with covid
a lot of bitcoin bulls and so on we're
expecting
that bitcoin would would be inversely
correlated with
these crashes and it would shoot through
the roof but that's not what happened
right um not what happened with gold
either and i think what was
underestimated was
how many people would need cash right
and when you need
cash you sell whatever you happen to
have and if
if you have for instance a lot of people
got themselves into trouble by
borrowing against assets so they took
out say
lines of credit based on the value of
their stocks
and then when the stocks cratered those
all got called and
you know bankers and everyone else
calling up
you know joe smith like hey joe smith we
want all our money right now
and they had to sell anything they could
sell that was liquid and that would
include a lot of crypto
so it took a few months for crypto to
recover to pre-covid
whereas gold kind of took off
immediately after covet it did drop
in the very short term like the kind of
early march to early april
and then kind of pick back up it wasn't
a big run-up though we never saw
kind of massive like the crypto like
gains that we've seen with bitcoin right
gold school's picked up a bit but not
not a ton
no no not that much and i'm referring to
gld specifically for people interested
but
uh what are what are your thoughts right
now on
all this crypto mania i mean there are
differences huge differences between
right now and 2017. sure namely
the entry of at least one of them is the
entry of institutional investors yes and
just a few months ago paul twitter jones
and
some other legends kind of dipping their
toe in the water
and beginning to make some allocations
in their portfolios uh fun portfolios
which is a big difference not just
personal
i believe that's true uh somebody can
fact check me but
what do you make of all this this is a
terrain that you're
much more familiar with than yeah i am
well
his my take is that with any
new crazy wild idea uh
come just a ton of skeptics as as there
should be
and when bitcoin was was first launched
and we were all playing around with
the very early wallets and i remember
just buying coins and picking them up
and i wasn't
really early early like i wasn't you
know in the pennies
but i was buying them around ten twelve
dollars a coin something like that
and uh you know it was it was the wild
west it was
very difficult to do anything to
to buy crypto to um you know we were all
setting up mining rigs back then
and trying to mine our own bitcoin and
then eventually pools came out so you
could join in with other people to do it
more efficiently
but this is fresh new technology they
hadn't been hammered and beaten on
and so you know anytime there's
something
that is directly linked to
your finances it takes years
or decades for people to get comfortable
with a new emerging technology to where
they'll
commit any serious capital to that
technology so
i think largely what we're seeing here
is well one it's it's
you know there's a lot of stimulus money
hitting the market there's a lot of
people buying on square cash app there's
you know it's much easier to purchase
bitcoin
than it has ever been you know it used
to be you have to go to
some shady exchange somewhere hold up a
picture of your
driver's license with like literally
your like date written underneath it to
make sure it was you
like shady stuff that i've been on some
of the exchanges my
identification has since been hacked on
many of these exchanges
thankfully i don't live in any of those
addresses that i had those ideas i was
holding up from the camera but i do get
text messages
of people trying to fish me all the time
like trying to like get me to like so
creepy
it's crazy it happens at least twice a
week it's insane
because my my information is out there
so whatever but
the point being is that it was extremely
difficult to get
um to purchase bitcoin and now you know
paypal came online
just a couple months ago and is offering
the ability to purchase bitcoin and
ethereum directly inside of paypal like
it's just insane how easy this is now
so you're unlocking massive customer
bases like hundreds of millions of users
with paypal you know square cash is the
i think the second or third largest
buyer now
of of bitcoin um that's on the retail
side
right this is just on the retail side
yeah so that's not even talking about
the institutional money going in right
so
you know i work at truventure's uh
venture capital firm
several billion dollars under management
we have positions in bitcoin
you know we've been doing that for a
while um so when you say you guys have
positions in bitcoin that means you've
invested in startups that focus on
bitcoin no that means we actually
own bitcoin how does that work
as a venture capital fund you're
operating the private endowment
yeah i mean every fund is a little bit
different um
you know in our specific case there we
have allocated
as part of our um you know formation
documents for the fund
a certain percentage of the fund can be
in cryptocurrency or cryptocurrency
related companies
so we can say i i'm just throwing out a
random number i i'd have to go look at
the docs see what the actual number is
but let's just say
10 15 of the fund overall fund size
you know we have 600 million dollar plus
fund that's you know that you can only
invest that much
from this specific fund into
cryptocurrency and so
uh you know if we're going to go into
and do a purchase
typically dollar cost average your way
in over a couple months and
and and buy in and in a place that that
has
really strong security like we don't
hold this ourselves it's not at our
office
like you're using like there's there's
big financial houses like fidelity and
coinbase custody and others that now
provide these types of services
you don't just have a bunch of hardware
wallets sitting in your jacket pocket
yeah it's uh right here
just in my house no i don't i actually i
don't i don't mess with that stuff
anymore i used to have wallets and
and i actually had a laptop that i would
i bought specifically for cryptocurrency
and i wanted to keep it in cold storage
meaning that
i back in the day when i was doing the
craziest like
coins you've never heard of on these
weird exchanges i
i went out i bought a laptop it was an
apple
um hooked it up to the internet did all
the software updates
like just put the wallets on there
transferred the funds and then
immediately powered it down so that it
wouldn't be online anywhere
hackable and then put it in a safe and
like that was the way i kept my
cryptocurrency
yeah it's crazy but but yeah so there's
been enough time has gone on
this current run-up though is just nuts
i mean
the thing you have to do with all these
things is just
don't look at the the last three months
because it looks like a decent graph and
you're like oh that looks reasonable
maybe i should buy something
like this look at the fire yeah zoom
into the five-year view the 10-year view
that's when you see
really what's happening here and it's
it's not even like a hockey stick it's
like it's
it's even more it's like insane how the
run-up has been and so i get
nervous when you see
you know it's it's always a good towel
around
well in this case it was like the the
virtual uh christmas or thanksgiving
dinner
when uncle harry is asking you if they
should be buying bitcoin like
that's when i like my my spidey sense
tingles a little bit and be like huh
everybody wants this now you know
there's it's just i i
i wouldn't be if if i were going to
enter the market now
i would do it in a way that is you pick
the dollar amount let's say it's a
thousand dollars and this is not
investment advice i'm just telling you
what i would do
pick a thousand dollars i would say okay
i want to own bitcoin i believe
in the future of bitcoin i think this
isn't going away which all those things
are true and
there are things that i believe uh it's
a proven technology now
um let's take that thousand dollars and
invest it over six months and so just
divide it up
by six and this do those i'll say the
first of every month and just go in
doesn't matter what the price is you
don't care you just buy that set amount
and that way you know at least you're
averaging your way in over over six
months
how do you personally think about crypto
for yourself as
part of your portfolio or percentage of
your total
i mean you're kind of famous for telling
not famous well you're famous to me for
telling me when i should buy stuff and
then not telling you when you've sold
stuff
which i pre which i appreciate uh so i
love that call by the way you're like
are you still holding this i'm like no i
sold it for like a 10x like six months
ago and you're like
i'm down or something bad will happen
we've been screwed by the fact that we
didn't talk yep that happens
with some fair frequency but uh what is
uh
what what is your current thinking in
terms of cryptocurrency
are you steering clear do you do you do
you still have a certain position
is it an investment for you is it an
insurance policy for you some people
have
drawn that distinction just sort of
philosophically as looking at
cryptocurrency as a
insurance policy i think that over time
as
uh well a few things one
let's just talk about the ecosystem in
general i think that 99
still today of the coins that you see on
the market out there
are just garbage i think a lot of them
and it's hard for them really
to go away they're just the volumes of
the volume and trades that happen just
decrease over time but they still have
these
you know somewhat impressive looking
market caps just sitting out there
very stagnant developers kind of drop
off it's just kind of like they're left
for dead but they're still around
so there's a lot of that um a lot of
interesting
innovation happening in the kind of
decentralized finance space so they call
it like defy
it's mostly happening on ethereum uh
so there's there's a handful of projects
where i say that's really interesting
it's almost like an
angel investment now i want to hold some
of that
but with the understanding that this
could go to 10
of the value it is today and so
extremely high risk
but you know still has the ability to
have a 50x
upside right so or at least a 20 or 30x
upside
i if you just look at the market cap of
a bitcoin today
there's not another 20 or 30 x anytime
soon coming to come into bitcoin it's
just
too big right like the market cap is
just too large you'd be
why do you now what how do you come to
that conclusion well i mean
first of all there's a few ways you can
do it i think that you just have to look
at the market cap in general which i
don't have in front of me right now but
i can
i can type it in um the other thing
is just look at the proxies for this so
like what is the market cap of gold
right of all gold out there and it's in
the trillions uh
let me see here so bitcoin right now
the market cap is 82.49 billion
so you know where would we be at if
that's a
10x from now like i mean that's just
insanity that's that's
i i can't imagine that happening anytime
soon it would just be
that's insane because of that because
that you might put next yeah
i mean apple is worth 2 trillion right
and so you know you just kind of have to
and i know it's not the same in that
we're not talking about um corporations
here with with
you know cash flows and pes and things
that we would typically use to
to to value a company that that is not
this the closest
proxy that i think most people draw the
comparison to is to just
gold you know what what is how much gold
has been mine how much
do we believe is there in the in the
earth what are people holding for an
investment
how much of it is actually being worn
like there's a lot of other ways so
there is a lot of potential upside in in
bitcoin but
for me i it's not that i wouldn't hold
it i
would definitely hold it i think it's
going to be a rocky bumpy ride given the
run-up that's had recently
like it's been forever like this has
always been the case of bitcoin it's
been very
bumpy but the new low is higher than the
last
low and it just continues to kind of
like it wouldn't surprise me to see this
drop down to
25 or 30 again but i don't think it's
going to get back to 10.
and there's just too many institutional
buyers coming in so
um you know i like it because there are
a lot of governments the u.s included
are probably one of the biggest
defenders
just printing money right now it's
really hard to understand
what the value of a dollar is or what it
will be in the future
this is a fixed number of
coins forever that will never change um
it's becoming it's universally accepted
you know
even more so every month uh all over the
world so
it's it's kind of a global reserve
currency that i i'm comfortable with so
i i do like it for that
um but i think there's a lot of new
interesting projects that probably
have more upside that also require more
due diligence and expertise right more
attention to detail so let's if we talk
about bitcoin
just to just to to continue on this
thread
it's it's currently at let's just call
it forty thousand dollars of bitcoin
and you were saying well it's hard to
see
a 20x upside if we look at proxies
or comparisons to gold or certainly if
we draw comparisons to apple
that's a little bit categorically i
guess a different comparison but
if we're looking at certain
trends or growth trends that have been
accelerated
thanks to or due to covid right if we
look at say
amazon or shopify
or peloton you know companies that we're
both quite familiar with
or and or investors in uh
a lot has been accelerated and the
the growth trajectory of the graph has
changed dramatically for
for a lot of companies sas companies
right adoption of remote work etc
could someone make an argument that
that is why in part at least we are
seeing this adoption
of bitcoin and that it is on some level
reasonable or i guess in your mind when
you're thinking of how much this price
can be
explained via factors
external happenings storming the capital
et cetera uh certainly
you know mmt and all this kind of stuff
uh
versus just pure mania right because the
the bitcoin bulls
will will sort of lay out
uh often regurgitated but sometimes
cogent arguments
for why this is uh explainable and
reasonable
and then the the bears
will say here's here's the
the tulip bulb craze of such and such a
year
and this is exactly what's happening
it's just pure mania there's nothing to
it besides
greed and human psychology run amok
where do you fall in thinking about
explaining the price because
if you look at institutional adoption
we're still super early
super early in institutional adoption
and
by institutional i mean there are wide
ranges of institutions
and certainly i think at the more
conservative end if we're talking about
endowments and pension funds and so on
it's
super early not to mention
sovereign wealth funds and so on right
the really like gigantic
the kind of nation state players so
yeah what do you think i mean it from an
institutional adoption
perspective it's super super early that
does not mean though
that the tiny amount of adoption up to
this point
plus square plus paypal have
organically produced forty thousand
dollar per bitcoin prices
right um um that's a that's a lot of
word salad i just threw at your face via
zoom yeah so
maybe you can speak to that well i i
think that
it's it's it's it is really hard
um if you look at the people that are
actually looking at the blockchain and
watching where assets are moving
some promising and also some really
scary things start to emerge
and so i i think the the promising side
is
just the average consumer now has
access to purchases with just a couple
clicks and apple pay and everything else
like that's the ease of purchase is gone
as as we mentioned earlier it's just
it's simple now
so that has unlocked certainly a lot of
demand especially around a hype
cycle we know about the institutional
side
i agree with you that it's very early
days there and there's been several
proposals and there are new ones out
there
for a bitcoin etf i think that happens
and we start seeing these appear in
people's 401k accounts and things just
go bonkers
um the scary side of things is some of
the price manipulation that's going on
and so you know there
are ways to manipulate the price and and
this is well i'll bring it up in in with
the caveat that
it's being talked about on the internet
so i'm bringing it up here it is not my
view that this is happening but it is
being talked on the internet so it's
worth mentioning
so i say that from a news perspective
not from an accusatory
uh perspective and that is that there is
a
lot of preamble for kevin well i'm just
i'm trying to say that because i don't
want them to come after me and like just
see the [ __ ]
basically so
so there's there's a there's a stable
coin out there when i mean stable coin
for
those people that don't know there are a
bunch of coins out there
that you can hold this cryptocurrency
that are pegged to
an asset like a fiat asset that we know
which like say the us dollar
so if you hold uh usdc is what it's
called the coin
and you hold one of those coins it is
worth one dollar and that never changes
just pegged at that price
and so there are a bunch of these and
one of the larger ones is called tether
the way the tether is supposed to work
is this if you send tether a thousand
dollars they issue you
a thousand dollars worth of tether coins
right that
makes sense if you go to redeem them
they give you back the thousand dollars
right
and so it kind of grew um
and well i shouldn't say kind of grow
it's massive now
and let me ask a novice question what is
the use case for that
why would someone do that they want a
mobile
they want stabilized they want stability
yeah so imagine you're sending
uh your aunt in costa rica a hundred
dollars and you wanna make sure a
hundred dollars gets there
not ninety two dollars because bitcoin
dropped you know or
or maybe she'd like if it went up but
you know it's like
it's you need the stability and it can
also be used for a whole slew of other
things they do lending with it
where you can our interest on it that's
where a lot of the decentralized finance
comes from anyway so a tether coin for
example
is is one of the first ones one of the
first stable coins and it has a 23.93
billion dollar market cap now there
are currently some ongoing
investigations
into what's going on behind the scenes
at tether because there are some
allegations
that they're just issuing new tether and
buying bitcoin
without there being the reserve usd to
actually back it up
so there's been a handful of articles
you can search
tether whatever you want to call it like
scandal or whatever you may be into
google news and you'll see that people
are looking at this and saying
huh they're they're and there's several
uh
organizations like government
organizations that are looking at this
and they're saying okay
we need to peer inside here and make
sure everything is kosher because if
it's not they could be just propping up
the bitcoin market and buying bitcoin
with fake
minted tether um stable coins and if
that's the case
and that comes out it's going to be
a [ __ ] show for a few days it's the best
that way i could just
do you think yeah that's probably uh
this [ __ ]
show uh do you think not knowing
anything about it that they have
sufficient volume to
prop up so to speak the bitcoin price
or to uh inflate it
well i mean just give you a sense in the
last 24 hours they've done 114.31
billion in volume
um so it's it's it's
heavily used on on some exchanges some
exchanges won't touch it
there's some there's some changes that
you won't even you can't even purchase
tether if you wanted to
um so it is the one piece
that i look at i just say ah gosh i
don't like where this is trending and
some of the people that are looking into
this
this could really put a big black eye on
the market it doesn't mean that bitcoin
is a fraud it has nothing to do with
bitcoin
bitcoin is a legitimate technology that
works well it's well secured
it's been hammered on like there's right
it doesn't mean this doesn't mean
bitcoin goes away but it does mean
that it's spooked the hell out of lots
of people
it supposes a lot of people and it also
shuts down
etf talks and all those other things
because a lot of the reasons why these
etfs
for bitcoin aren't being approved is
because of these claims
of this type of market manipulation so
you know but to your earlier ask around
like what do you how do you think of
this when it comes to portfolio
construction
um and again i'm a venture capitalist
not a registered
investment advisor this is not financial
advice but for me personally
i think informational purposes only this
is informational and entertainment
purposes
oh you bastard that's not true you're
gonna cut that out you
rat bastard um so
so basically um i would say for me
personally i think
okay maybe up to five percent of my
overall
portfolio and consider it super high
risk
but i like your strategy tim it's like
you it's kind of one you have to take
with cryptocurrency
if this gets cut in half or cut in three
quarters you just have to say
huh okay bad day bad week bad month and
just
write it out for the next 10 years
because you know in 10 years it will
bounce back and the returns were going
to look better than ever so
you know that's kind of how you have to
play it yeah and it's a it's a test of
conviction and process also
right in the sense that uh i've been
talking to
you know friends and like you sort of
the kind of uncle harry
equivalents are like i want to put money
into bitcoin and ethereum
and i'm like can you tell me what
bitcoin
is and they can't even hazard a guess
it's just something that's going up in
value very quickly
and is your uncle actually harry i don't
wanna throw this guy under the bus
that's made up okay good
okay so okay so uncle harry usually will
have a story that is something like this
my friend bob has invested in crypto
and over the last seven months
he's made let's just make up a number
you know five hundred thousand dollars
and my question is always did he sell
all of his bitcoin and pull out five
hundred thousand dollars
and the answer is no and my my follow-up
to that is well
it all looks good on paper but if it's
not enough to just buy something that is
going
up in value unless you believe it's
going to go up in value indefinitely you
also have to have a plan
for if and when you are going to sell
that asset and redeem now
some pure believer or true believers
would say you never sell bitcoin and
that's one
option but unless unless you have
deliberately conscientiously decided
that and you have that as a
bulletproof emotion proof strategy you
sure as hell better have a plan
uh for if and when you are going to
redeem
to some type of fiat and if you don't
have a defined time horizon
the likelihood of you losing money
because you sell
in a panic when it plummets is pretty
goddamn high
that's why i like the lower percentage
points of your overall portfolio because
it has to be
money that doesn't matter so you can
hold it for the long term if you want to
do it hold it for the next 20 years
but i guess what you're saying is it
does get to meaningful money at some
point right because naturally
if it if it does 5x from here or 10x
from here
then it's gonna be no longer five
percent of your portfolio right so
in that case like i would force myself
to
every year or every other year just
rebalance
so like do you do you actually do that
though because
there are honors you do i did it with
pelton
okay all right so you so now you would
do that
uh regardless of the
the duration of holding that investment
or do you wait
for long long-term cap gains right i
mean like
is there i would wait for long-term cat
gains unless
it is something just absolute bonkers
so if it's if it's absolute bonkers and
you're just like i mean
look at tesla right now just like look
at that chart click on the five year
and and your apple stocks app
it's it's just like the you're like how
is it not bending over i feel like fault
it should fall backwards it's going so
high like it's
just it's ridiculous and and so you
if you i'm if i'm holding short-term
capital i just want to point out that
you're also
you are also a lover of tesla products
right so like you're not
saying this is as a tesla hater you love
their stuff i have i have
listen i have two teslas they're
fantastic vehicles they're they're my
favorite i
i have a truck on order i can't wait to
get that thing and yet
when it's a straight line yeah
yeah so it's you know it's it's just one
of those things where
if it is getting an outsized percentage
of your portfolio then it just it's
absolutely smart to
and i kind of have this thing where your
overall overall mixture of of assets
and everything that you have kind of put
together like what is your allocations
for
multiple things look like and i'm
most of my stuff is just fully
diversified set it and forget it forever
like wealthfront style just put it in
there and have it be fully diversified
and safe
and then i have a category that is like
let's just call it 25
of my overall assets that'll say these
are 5x capable stocks
or greater and those i know they're
super risky well
somewhat risky and they have real cash
flow and all that but um
i'm going to invest in those and i'll
put like you know pelotons in that kind
of camp
some of the more riskier stuff like the
neos like the the chinese tesla
um you know a few other things that that
um
that i've bought over the last few
couple years so you know
it's but then then always going and
pruning and readjusting and saying oh
actually my 5x stocks are now 40 of my
portfolio
let's trim that back to 25. yeah i
appreciated your strong buy
recommendation on pornhub
that was uh that was genius well you're
code you're your co-owner now which is
odd but it's it's your thing
the acro yoga i'm on the team i'm on the
team tab
free premium for the next two months use
code tim tim tim tim kevkev
i really hope they make that code that
would be fantastic that is a joke
people joke joke joke joke kev kev uh
now the follow-up is really more
commentary because
i i think some people will be very
interested in this conversation and
others will will find it uh inside
baseball or just
they'll think that it's kind of uh
rarefied air investment talk and
i i would on one level agree with that
on one
level disagree with it because we're
sitting here at the beginning of 2021
2020 has been
such a fascinating and punishing
laboratory for looking at the
consequences of good and bad decisions
and there are many places where it's
difficult to
quantify those upsides and downsides
and risks certainly with covid with
certain information available other
information unavailable
or pending it's been challenging but
one of the playing fields in which
you can look at decision making as sort
of a microcosm
of the macro right like you get to see
how
decision making that transcends
investing
shows itself with stocks crypto whatever
it might be right
in other words if you are able to
observe and hone your decision making
with even very small investments i
believe that that transfers
into if you're if you're self-aware that
can
transfer into better decision making in
other areas right because we're all
investors of time energy
capital and you can choose to become
better at those things or you can remain
blissfully unaware
but one way or another you are making
decisions about investment
every day so that's that's another
reason why i've
paid attention to this a lot in the last
year i mean i think there have been
some incredible opportunities also
uh in in the last 12 months but
more than that it's just a lens through
which you can
look at how rational
you are how subject to emotional swings
and corresponding bad decisions you are
and it tells you a lot
about how you might make decisions or
or more concretely make rules for
yourself in 2021
so can you give me an example of that
like i'm really curious outside of
finance how have you applied this to
other areas of your life
well uh so for instance in in 2020 one
of the biggest lessons
or takeaways that i had for myself in
investing then i'll talk about
how i would apply that this is going to
sound so
rudimentary but you know i i've i've
been very
lucky and also i think very good at
picking things to invest in
over time right if you just look at the
last 10 years 12 years
net net things have worked out pretty
well and there are a lot of
circumstances there are certain trends
that i accidentally took advantage of
some that i deliberately took advantage
of but blah blah blah blah i'm pretty
good at
placing bets i am i am very
weak i would say on exit strategy and
knowing when to get out of positions
and this past year
i realized that three years
looking at a three-year time horizon for
anything publicly traded
seems to be a incredibly comfortable for
me
in the sense that i can't predict what
things are gonna do
what what companies are gonna do what in
the next three months six months i have
no [ __ ] idea
no idea right uh i mean they're just so
many curveballs that can be
served to any company uh
five years i mean geez five years now
we're talking about like google
starting to usurp yahoo right i mean
that's like a long enough period of time
especially
with exponentially developing
technologies that five years is
very hard to call but like three years
if i'm looking at certain types of
companies that i feel like i understand
pretty well
amazon shopify would be two examples
i think spotify also um i'm investors in
all of those
and again this is not investment advice
i don't know how many times we have to
say this to cover our assets but
this is uh you know your mileage may
vary
and i only invest in things that i feel
like i i really
really understand deeply and i'm the
same way
yeah so three years i'm looking at
certain trends
i have an audience fortunately and a lot
of friends
who are kind of the tip of the spear
with early adoption not all of those
things work out
but when you see then it begin to kind
of
hop like hop the fence from
say my friends or my audience to people
one degree removed i'm like okay
that that i think is worth paying a lot
of attention to
so that is that has been a a new rule
that i've established for myself
specifically for
uh publicly traded equities and uh
the way that that's applied to my
life more broadly and we're gonna we're
gonna don't worry folks we're gonna get
to other points besides crypto and
investing
is you know doing a full review of 2020
and then looking forward to 2021
thinking out three years as opposed to
just
2021 and thinking
about what types of sort of
regularly occurring practices i want to
have and i can give some examples when
we get into it
over a three year period is is really
calming for me mm-hmm
i think yeah like 10 years 10 years it's
kind of like i don't know man i mean
there's just so much that could change
i mean who knows if you know cal
you know like texas is going to secede
along like maybe texas and montreal
will become sister cities and you know
or
whatever sister provinces and they'll
secede from the nation
i'm i'm being a bit ridiculous with that
but
like 10 years is a long long time and a
lot can happen
three years i just find that to be a
very
calm place for me when it comes to
planning
now but also thinking about personal
development
and building a family and so on and so
forth
uh so it's kind of like if you were to
paddle out
in the ocean at like a surf break right
you would
you when you first paddle out let's just
say it's a beach break for simplicity
like you're gonna have to get through
these these first sets of waves
and then you're going to have some calm
and then you're going to get to like the
outer breakers and you're going to be in
the impact zone again and it's going to
be
exciting but it's also can be really
stressful and i find like three years
for me it's just kind of comfortably
in between those two yeah yeah i like
what you said about
also uh doing these kind of thematic
investing where you say okay i don't
know
i i like you you just named off the
exact same companies that i pay
attention to
around e-commerce because like obviously
we know e-commerce is
is well it's more so online these days
than ever but
it's still a fraction of in-person
commerce right so
if we believe that trend is going to
continue which it will
you know who are the players in that
space and and so rather than say well
actually i think it's gonna be amazon
and not shopify
or square you know it's like i i just
would rather
own the entire bucket right so
you know i i go and get amazon shopify
square um paypal and i think that
pretty much covers you know the future
of payments when i think about
like mobile payments and and just
happening on your phone and eventually
when coinbase goes public i'll probably
pick some of that up as well but like
just having that
and sitting on those and then just
watching and kind of
as leaders start to emerge kind of
dollar cost average in a little bit more
to get a little bit more upside in the
in the clear winners if there are going
to be any
then that's that's kind of what what
i've done uh historically this that's
proved to be pretty
successful yeah and it's you know we're
talking about kind of pickaxes and
shovels
right i mean in the sense that a lot of
these companies not all of them
uh but a lot of these companies offer
services that
other companies capitalize on or other
creators
and my choices also were based on
different scenarios related to covid so
i was like okay let's say covid
like wave a magic wand it gets solved
tomorrow
but we were decimated behaviors changed
growth trajectories changed for let's
just call it
severely for like six to 12 months okay
what does that look like for an amazon
what does that look like for shopify
okay and then let's say kovid continues
let's say there's a new strain and a b
and c happens and rather than best case
it's
it's it's certainly maybe not worst case
but
uh a terrible case what does that look
like for these various companies
okay and just came to the conclusion
personally
that in most
scenarios you could play out as an
exercise
these companies still seem to do well
and right but you also have to play out
the other side too right like
what what happens once the vaccine
happens and code subsides
this is why i'm not holding zoom right
now and zoom may be a great
it's a great company great product we're
using it right now but it's like
it's i i just don't see you know when
people start to return to work what gets
hit the hardest and yeah so that's
that's part of the reason why
i mean i missed out on a ton of upside
with was the climate and rise of zoom
but
it doesn't pass that post-vaccine test
i want to i want to have to believe in
my heart of hearts that i will close my
eyes and hold this thing for five years
and before doing an investment otherwise
it's just it's gambling at that point
yeah well i mean it it depends on how
you define your time horizon and if you
have the skills
and the emotional control
or stoicism to be able to stick to your
plan
right so for me i ca one of the reasons
i came to three years is again
five years i just don't have confidence
that i can look into the crystal ball
and understand where technology is going
to be in five years there are companies
i expect will still be around
certainly but let's just take in the
case of spotify for instance
you know i looked at spotify really
closely and i'm on spotify like i
understand the technology i use the
product
and uh i saw them investing incredibly
heavily
in non-music audio content
and uh certainly at the top of that list
in terms of their capital expenditures
uh would be podcasts and you have rogan
you've got all these different folks
and uh four
compared to say amazon there are people
who would argue
that podcasts are an existential
priority right like they
have to really heavily invest and
be the a player high bidder for
a lot of this core talent and these
teams who can create content
because their economic model
is in some respect dependent on
the improved margins through non-music
audio right amazon sells
everything right amazon sells a million
things
and amazon music and you know the team
who's on podcasts uh with amazon is a
is a fantastic team but within
amazon itself it's hard for me to to
imagine that that has the same
level of urgency and priority that
it would have for spotify just given the
range of options
so for me but what about apple yeah
apple's huge but apple
also is i think uh
apple's amazing they have by far the
most market share right now
and they're also uh they have i would
i would expect like certain constraints
right like i don't think they're going
to
pursue anything incorporating
advertising models at least not in the
short term
right they just haven't had a lot of
luck with that
they don't seem inclined to pursue it uh
also again just because the like what is
the lion's share of
apple revenue i have to imagine it's
hardware and apple care and so on i mean
the
sort of incremental revenue ad is
is pretty nominal when it is compared to
say
spotify who is like absolutely has to
make this work so for me i'm like all
right
apple amazon are going to be really
deliberate
they're not going to rush they have
endless
powder in the keg right like they just
have once they find
things that work they can they can make
them ubiquitous
i think that's going to take time is it
going to happen in one year
uh maybe but i think pretty unlikely
which is why i think spotify will
continue i mean if i had to guess to
invest
very heavily in trying to solidify their
position as
the go-to platform for
sort of talent and content creation
within
the kind of predefined parameters of
non-music audio so for that reason this
is not the only reason but for that
reason
also looking at potential upside right i
mean in the sense that like
if you want amazon to double what needs
to happen for that to happen
right yeah and then if you look at
spotify for spotify
to double what might need to happen in
order for that to be
the reward that the market and retail
investors
sort of bestow upon it and
the answer is i mean i feel like a lot
less needs to happen
for spotify right i'm not saying spotify
would ever do this but like if spotify
were just to redomicile
and avoid all of these various problems
that they have
with the their current uh
situation not that they would do that
but like certainly
there are steps they could take if they
needed to that would dramatically change
their financials
um and again what what the hell do i
know right like i'm not
an analyst but uh yeah but this is your
world though i mean podcasting is like
that's your dna
so i feel like you know a lot when it
comes to that
yeah yeah i mean i just i and i also see
and you and i have texted about this
where
people you wouldn't have expected to use
spotify are now using spotify
yeah right and it's made that hop
over the fence in the united states
in europe the behaviors are very
different uh in
spanish-speaking countries uh and
regions
spotify is extremely dominant it would
appear based on polling my own audience
and there's just a lot of
there's a lot of room to grow i think
the the yeah i agree with that like i
think spotify
is interesting from that standpoint it
is certainly
um it's a it's a really crappy
razor thin margin business on the music
side
anytime they can get you anywhere away
from one of the major
labels they're making money right
because you're pa you're paying that 15
a month or whatever is 12 a month um i
just found out they have a uh
i downgraded from the family plan to the
duo plan
which is just for two people so my wife
and i just use the dual plan and save my
bucks
myself three bucks a month well done
thank you
thank you um anyway yeah so
it's a great product too i love the
technology i think that they
have invested heavily on the kind of ai
machine learning side of things to get
recommendations better than anyone has
which is
so key for music discovery um so yeah
it's it's a
it's i i'm a fan on that front as well
yeah um and one more thing yeah i was
going to say one more thing on the
finance side as well
and move on because i know we had a few
topics to hit but yeah
i spent a crap ton of time
uh researching and doing my due
diligence on the
various uh financial applications for
tracking finances
so um i just wanted to share this with
people because i let my work
uh benefit you in some way so uh you
know
i feel that what i've done is is i
you know all of us or most of us we
dabble in a bunch of things whether it
be
cryptocurrency or a little bit of like
you know e-trade or whatever your
brokerage or wealth front or
you have a little bit of stuff here you
have maybe you have a home or not or a
car payment or not
and i want a universal dashboard to
bring all that stuff together
it's like one place where you can see
holistically what's going on with all of
your finances everywhere credit cards
all that stuff
and i've tried all of the stuff out
there real quick
quicken sucks it's horrible it doesn't
work with like half the crap out there
it won't tie the wealth front it won't
tie a bunch of stuff
it's just horrible so avoid that at all
cost even though that's like the old
school one it sounds like oh maybe maybe
quicken's better now it's not better it
sucks
now i i have this theory that a bunch of
the quicken
engineers got together and were like
yeah this place kind of sucks but let's
go create a new product
so quicken came out with a new product
that is that is actually quite good it
says it's called simplify
so it's simplify money.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-f-i you can just google it
don't
like try and spell that um anyway
simplify from
it's by the makers of quicken so i
it is actually a fantastic product uh
and it's somehow competing against
quicken their own product which is very
weird
i think what happened is as with any old
piece of software
you've got an old school audience that's
been baked in for decades
that if you change any user interface
element they go
ape [ __ ] and they freak out on you right
like that's the case with why all these
software packages like word and excel
and all these others they just are
turning into bloatware you know you look
at them you're like why so many icons
and it's because people will complain if
you remove anything
it's always hard to take features out so
this is just a really streamlined
beautiful it's like three bucks a month
it's fantastic now
if you don't like this um oh
one thing i do like about this i'll just
tell you one of the features i thought
was really cool and i used this uh for
over the holidays you know how like you
you go and you return something like
you got a sweater you return it but you
like never know if it really hits your
account again you don't pay attention
like
it became there's a way to say i return
this and notify me when i get the credit
back or not if the credit doesn't come
back
like there's some really like cool
little features like that so anyway i
was pretty impressed that it does link
with a lot of the stuff
very confusing why it links with a lot
of the places that quick and doesn't
even know the same company
but anyway that's that i think personal
capital though
is the best one that's out there have
you used personal capital before
no um i don't use them on the investing
side like i don't
put my money with them because they also
have like an investing thing i use
wealthfront for that
but personal capital is in terms of the
interface the holistic interface to
bring together all the accounts
it's completely free you don't have to
spend any money on it and it kind of
brings
everything into one dashboard for you um
so anyway i i've looked at like 10
others that i won't even bore you with
but but those are my
my picks for the show sweet what what
now you are how would i put it
um you have a financial dashboard
fetish uh like
some people like tentacle porn like
japanese
japanese coffee which you also like but
you have a financial dashboard fetish
so what i'm curious about is
do you just does it just tickle your
balls and you get a little
feeling in your butterfly in your uh
makes you really happy to look at this
is it just like a zen garden for you
or do you actually learn anything does
it inform your decisions has it changed
how you behave in any way
it it has because what it does is
it does a pretty good job at kind of
categorizing
everything that's going on in my life
and so it has a beautiful cash flow
feature where i can see i've spent this
much this was my budget
um and this is how much income i have
coming in so i like to kind of
track that and watch the trends over
time and
overall net worth is cool because it
lets you tie in your house in there
let's put your cars in there like
anything else that you may have any
jewelry anything
and you can kind of like watch as
certain things appreciate or they don't
and they go down it's just like
i i like the idea of
being able to pull all this stuff
together into like one interface because
if you think about okay now i gotta go
log into coinbase and now i gotta go log
into wealthfront and now i gotta go
log into my bank to see my checking
account oh and i have a credit card over
at chase and i have
an apple pay card and like there's a
bunch of stuff to check you know and
and that means in terms of transactions
as well i mean i've caught some fraud on
these
and it alerted me to things where i was
like i didn't buy that i wouldn't cancel
the card
so just having a way that i can go and
every couple days
just see that and just do a quick gut
check like is everything sane here
it's nice and there's no i don't have to
log into multiple places and it's it's
free so
i don't know it's cool so you avoid
logging into multiple places
by giving all of your login information
to one entity or is there some type of
auth
that allows you to circumvent that like
ulcer producing
centralization which would make me
nervous yeah so plaid
is it powers all of this on the back end
so plaid is a company
you may or may not have heard of it was
one that we invested in when i was at
google ventures
um and it they work with all the
financial institutions
to connect and provide data
to apps like personal capital so you're
actually not
sharing your login credentials with
plaid or with
personal capital you're sharing them
with plaid plaid secures them
they issue like a token to personal
capital so personal capital never
actually has your credentials
um and then they can view your data that
through through that
one like secured vault so cool
it is nice like that yeah i was worried
about that as well
i will add one more thing on the finance
front which is i'm
[ __ ] tired of thinking about anything
related to
finance or investing or that's been you
forever dude
yeah for five years yeah that's true
that's true
but especially uh especially
in the last i would say six to 12 months
so my
one of my goals is to do as much
possible in terms of batching activities
or
setting rules for myself like strict
rules like you can't eat bagels i don't
eat bagels anyway although they're
delicious but like
making very binary rules for myself
because i think it is very easy
and if we look at just human behavior i
think it's
it's very natural but often
harmful to one's health if you
have something that is moving up or down
or an up and down if you have something
easily quantifiable
that that to your mind seems like points
on the scoreboard whether positive or
negative
it's really easy to spend a lot of time
being distracted by these things and
looking at these things
and it's i i'm thinking a lot
more about energy management over the
next
year than time management i feel like
time management
should be a downstream decision based
on your energy management priorities and
rules
and that is how i'm approaching it so
i am hoping to do effectively zero
investing unless i have to make
defensive moves or
disaster befalls me which i hope will
not be the case
so that is all to say
i kind of crammed a lot of decisions
because as you know kevin i was sitting
on the sidelines since
i don't know 2015 with the exception of
that crypto
position and uh i don't enjoy it in the
same way that that some of my friends do
and maybe you do just the like
the tracking of all of it i feel like uh
it's kind of a leeching of energy
for me even though it is very addictive
so i'm looking forward to doing things
that have nothing to do with investing
and
we were talking about in in prep for
this conversation
talking about or i guess in the in the
google spreadsheet talking about
this year meaning 20 2021
uh new year's resolutions last year and
i do every year for the last handful of
years a past year review where i go
through my calendar
week by week from the previous year
and look at the things that gave me the
most energy
took the most energy some of them are
worth it most of them are not
and trying to identify the kind of peak
emotional
experiences positive and negative and
who the people and activities are
on both those lists so i'm sorry to say
kevin you ended up on
my negatives i'm kidding
[Laughter]
and and that's how i then go through and
look at scheduling things
and spending time or not spending time
with activities in people for the next
year
and the most consistent energy giver
was time in nature and
activities in nature which is part of
the reason i was so thrilled and we can
kind of go in any direction
but to get as a gift this book which is
of wolves and men by barry
holston lopez and it is probably the
best non-fiction book i've read in the
last five years it is
so cool unbelievably good
uh and i have highlights
on almost certainly in every chapter
and it's it's just i i had to modify the
way i highlighted because i highlighted
so much
his writing is as crisp
and clear as michael lewis the structure
of his writing
is right up there with like john mcphee
and
the the beauty of his prose and just the
word smithing
and use of metaphor is right up there i
would say with mary oliver i was
blown away i kept stopping my friends
and wanting to read them
paragraphs and chapters and they got
pretty annoyed after a while but
uh it is a spectacular
non-fiction book very cool yeah it's uh
and it's funny tim i don't know if you
remember telling me this but you
told me i don't know maybe was it six
months ago you were like i'm not reading
any new books
what was it you're saying something like
that what was that oh yeah so well for
i read no books that were printed in 20
uh that were published
in 2020. so i was reading
books but i i put up a blog post
as a policy and i think the title of the
blog post was making
the single decision that removes a
thousand decisions
and that relates to the
burden of getting hit up by hundreds of
people a year who want me to read their
books
that are coming out you know a week
later or two months later
and it's not that they're bad people but
they they very often
have a book coming out they want to be
on the podcast and
i end up often times where i have ended
up with just
stacks of hundreds of books and the fact
of the matter is
we don't have that much time on the
planet you know unless we figure out how
to
you know recycle you know 20 year old
blood like vampires like some people do
who shall not be named or whatever using
fancy drugs rapamycin metformin etcetera
like maybe you get you eek out a few
more years okay that's possible but
if i look at the average age of death of
males in my family going back many
generations as far as i could
like easily do the math it's about 85.
like it doesn't really matter what you
do as long as you don't get hit by a bus
or fall off a cliff like you're probably
going to die around 85
so i'm 43 that means i've crossed the 50
mark i think it's helpful to just assume
that
and you can sit down and do the math
like
how many really good books do you read
per year
and people do the math and maybe they
end up at five maybe they end up at 20.
it's hard to read 20 amazing books
unless you're really deliberate about it
you probably read a fair amount of
garbage
uh and so you figure out like okay
this you know this book took me a long
time to find
and it was gifted to me even though it
had been recommended many times i still
didn't read it
you said a long time to find meaning you
just hadn't heard of it or it's out of
private no
no no it's not out of print it's it's uh
a long time to find it took a long time
for it to happen i guess is what i'm
saying it had been recommended many
times
but we get bombarded with reading
assignments all day long right maybe
it's
just something on tick tock or instagram
or twitter or
whatever although i deleted all of those
from my phone
i deleted yeah all of those have been
deleted from my phone for about
six months now which is great uh wait i
saw you post on instagram the other day
i didn't see you post daria told me you
did because i don't i don't have that uh
i don't i don't go on
instagram yeah yeah i do know uh she
told me because you
posted the chocolate bar that we got you
i did yeah so i
have a workaround so the way that i
post to instagram without using
instagram here's this thing
no i use i use and well i mean that
sometimes happens too but i use
an app called only pult and
only pulse like a catapult but only
pulse pult
allows me to post to instagram without
having
the application on my phone so i'm sure
there are other things that allow you to
do this maybe hootsuite or others but uh
i've used only pult
and it's it's really kind of a it is
not a swiss army knife it is for what is
this thing just like
instagram and ascii like you're like
scrolling
i like your assistant is calling you up
and being like
kevin is wearing a red shirt today and
daria seems to be holding their dog like
describing you post by pose
yeah i'm like take out the semicolon who
uses semicolons
no i uh i use only pulled it
think of it as a buffer for instagram
specifically so you can
schedule social media posts or post
immediately
using this application and
it posts to your instagram account for
you so what that allows me to do is i
can take a photo of something i think
it's beautiful
or useful put it on
instagram and do so without ever being
exposed to my feed in any way so i'm
it is it is in other words it is right
only
instead of read-only i mean you could
just unfollow everyone too and then when
you go
both there's like a blank feed yeah i
mean i could do that but then you don't
get the dms and stuff i guess
but how do you look at your dms i don't
really use dms
yeah i don't either um yeah it's just
it's just over
uh the volume isn't manageable so uh
the the point being with these books is
like
look at your track record of reading
books and i remember
tim urban wrote about this uh so the the
creator of
of weight book y uh in an amazing piece
called the tail end which everyone
should read
and it talks about how precious
time actually is everybody listening to
this if you haven't read the tail end by
tim merbin
read it re-read it i reread it regularly
and the fact of the matter is like i
don't know maybe i have a few
a few hundred books left to read like
good ones
so i don't want to be reading stuff
generally speaking that hasn't stood
some test of time right like this guy
barry lopez won the national book award
he was nominated for the national book
award for this
book of wolves and men i mean this this
is a very high bar right they just
published the 25th anniversary
edition it changed how people wrote
about
nature or how people thought about
constructing
nature writing and non-fiction period
like the guy completely
reshaped an entire genre of writing it's
it's incredible
and if you have that high a bar there
are still too many books
so i'm trying to be much more purposeful
about my reading
and that was why in 2020 i had i'm not
reading any books published this year
which i am
going to extend for 2021 so i'm not
going to read any books published in
2021 either
that's awesome i love that yeah feels
good
and once you make the rule it
depersonalizes it this is really
important
because it's hard to say no when you're
making
one-off decisions right if somebody
comes to you and they're like hey can
you
contribute to my gofundme because you
know i lost my shoes and i want to buy
a nice pair of shoes or whatever you
just get hit up with so much stuff
and if if it is a personal no
it's hard for people to receive if it is
a policy
and you can point them somewhere uh
even if you say it's a policy it often
takes the sting out but i could just
point to
if you go to tim dot blog forward slash
uh
new books i think it is like it it's a
short url that takes people directly
to that post on the
finding single decisions that remove
hundreds or thousands of
decisions and uh
yeah there it is yeah so if you just go
to team.log forward slash
new books then it takes you to finding
the one decision that removes 100
decisions
and so if i get hit up via email via
text via
fill in the blank by someone i actually
know who wants me to read a book i'm
just like you know i wish i could but i
can't i've set this public policy
so i don't have to choose among friends
boom and i send a link
and that's that's it that's the template
response
can i ask you yeah how you um
well let me i'll i'll tell you why i'm
asking this question i'm asking this
question because
as part of the training that i'm doing
with with henry who we talked about on a
previous uh
podcast who's a the zen master that i
study with
um one of the things that i do is when i
go for walks in nature and you mentioned
enjoying nature as one of the the big
highlights um
it the the easy thing to do
is to put on a podcast or an audiobook
right and
on top of that is to set it at two and a
half speed so you can get through as
fast as possible
um my instructions have been to take out
my headphones
and just treat it as a as a way to
listen
just listen to nature just like let it
all come in
and put your focus and attention on the
sounds that are
happening around you i found that to be
a much more it's like a like a
amplifier on top of the already awesome
walk
uh just this idea of of really being
there rather than try and do
extra things while you're on that walk
right and so my question is
you know when i've been listening to
audiobooks i've actually said okay 1x
feed
because i really if i'm going to do a
book i'm going to give it my full
attention
are you doing anything like that or do
you jam through books do you read them
at night like
how do you consume well
so there are a few things i'd love to
reflect on that you just said
the the first as far as nature goes
uh i would say that and i try to think
about
much like the energy management leading
then to time management
i think a lot as you know about the the
sequencing of things like what is the
natural kind of
waterfall cascade order in which these
things belong
and for me spending time in nature
is about cultivating an a
very detailed awareness of nature
or acute awareness of nature first and
foremost
if i do that the enjoyment or the
the contentment that i feel in nature
automatically goes up
dramatically so i i spent and part of
the reason i'm thinking about this so
much is i've had a very hard time
reacclimating to
austin and it's not because of all the
swarms of locusts
aka californians descending upon this
fair city
although i'm hypocritical to say that
obviously uh it's
it's it's because it's a city it's a
city and i spent
a lot of time in the wilderness uh on
athena on a farm
i don't want to mention locations but uh
for the entire summer so you know i
spent several months
walking through the woods every day
where there are black bear and
coyotes and so on and seeing the changes
i would walk for hours
and i got to recognize these
very minor or i should say my newt
changes
on my walks i would see which trees
changed color first as we got closer
to autumn i would see uh
how tracks presented themselves in
certain places at certain
times of the day and it depended on
whether
and when i came back to austin i want to
say
one one thing also one of the ways that
i
increased my appreciation for what was
around me
because i think if if the walk isn't
interesting enough for you you're
probably just not interested
enough uh so i i asked
and i'm going to be you know finding
someone to pay
to help me with this in austin found
wildlife biologists and
specialists or even people who work at
say
garden shops and things like that to
walk with me through the woods to
identify things to point things out to
me
and you know the recommendation they
gave me at one point
was start with trees because flowers and
wildflowers are very complex there
there are going to be dozens if not
hundreds of different varieties start
with the trees because in in any given
location
you might have at least where i was
let's just call it 8-12 trees and if you
learn
the classifications and how to tell them
apart and how to describe the different
characteristics that separate them
or distinguish them you're going to be
able to identify
90 of the trees that you see how cool is
that
you know before that point in time
they're just trees
you might identify a maple let's say
because the leaf looks like the
something you'd see in canada but by and
large
it's just trees it's green stuff that's
really high
and after that you
suddenly kind of click the dial a few
notches towards
high def and your experience of the walk
changes tremendously
so i would occasionally take phone calls
when i was walking
but i spent i would say at least seventy
eighty percent of my time
listening to bird calls learning to
identify birds
uh they're a bird are you i'm not a
birder
i'm not a birder it's okay if you are no
no i'm not a birder someone will be able
to find this
there is actually an app on android
sadly not
last i checked it wasn't on ios that is
like shazam for bird calls
it's amazing in other words you can hold
your phone up
click a button and it will identify
which bird is calling which is awesome
are you doing this are you doing shazam
for birds out in the forest
no because i use ios i use ios so i had
to do it the old-fashioned way and like
go online and listen to different bird
calls and try to compare them
the the uh the
other thing that i that i found really
fun to do
because not everyone's gonna have access
to someone who can point out different
plants
is to use the google app
to do uh image searches on different
plants
and uh it is incredibly
accurate most of the time i was stunned
it's so cool
like just walk around your house like
how many people and i'm gonna plead
guilty here
know the names or the types of all the
plants they might have in
in or around their houses very very few
i would guess
right and using the google app
and image search which is very easy you
can
pretty quickly identify the vast
majority of plants trees and so on it's
awesome i've used it on
walks here in austin to identify trees i
love that
yeah so those are a few of the ways that
i think about
nature of which we are apart right it's
very easy to feel separate from nature
and i think that feeling of separateness
is
intensified if you have earbuds in and
you're listening to something at rapid
speed
nature doesn't really rush right so to
to meet it
at its own cadence without listening
to anything but what is around you i i
find really therapeutic
as far as reading these days
i definitely don't rush like if i'm
rushing through a book
i should generally just drop the book
it's not good enough
uh like this book like you should be you
should only be
choosing books that you are sad to see
end
um right like if you're not like oh man
what am i going to do
now that i finish oh no i have to find
another book if you don't have that
feeling
then you're not reading the right books
i'll give you another example
so this book is one that i was uh
i was given by my girlfriend for
christmas and it's an
awesome book uh i hadn't read it
in probably 20 years and it's
it's this it's called exploring the
world of lucid dreaming
by stephen labiersch l-a-b-e-r-g-e
and howard ryangold this is an
incredibly detailed
uh tactical how-to book
about lucid dreaming and developing
the different skills related to
lucid dreaming and lucid dreaming i was
really
really dedicated to a lot of these
practices towards the
very end of high school or certainly the
first few years of college and i
actually reached out
to stephen labarris or his team when i
was in college
i couldn't get a hold of him but i did
get the attention of his team because i
said
you may want to look at if you haven't
already hooper zine
a hooper's in a is a supplement you can
get it anywhere
certainly online which acts as an
acetylcholinesterase inhibitor
and this this is just a very long-winded
way something sad
well i mean it's not just choline in the
brain well
it's it's not turning off acetylcholine
production
but it it has anecdotally
the ability to help one induce
lucidity how and why that happens i
don't know at the time i had a very
you know well-developed pet theory for
why this
sort of mechanistically and plausibly
why it worked but
uh the point being that stephen laberge
came out of stanford
lucid dreaming to define that is the
phenomenon
of realizing that you are dreaming when
you are dreaming
so you you effectively wake up in your
dream
and you're like holy [ __ ] i'm dreaming
and normally you get excited and then
you wake up
yeah they call that they call that in
zen they call that enlightenment
but it's not when you're dreaming there
you go yeah you're awake and you wake up
and yeah this is a dream yeah so
you can start with you could start with
the lucid dreaming see how you do it
with that uh but this is this is
actually a
phenomenon that can be demonstrated in
laboratory settings because your eye
movements during rem sleep
uh correspond to your eye movements in
dreams so
you could hook someone up to i supposed
to be an eeg
in a sleep lab uh you will know when
they are sleeping
uh and in rem states and so on based on
brainwave activity
and then if if they have agreed with the
experimenter
on a predefined set of eye movements
let's just say like
right right left right right left or
something like that
when they become lucid in their dream
they could look
in that following that pattern and
indicate to someone who is
in the lab that they are in fact aware
they're dreaming it's pretty well they
could just be closing their eyes and
doing that
well they wouldn't be able to pull that
off because the the eeg wouldn't show it
right
that's right the eeg wouldn't would
would just show that there have been
[ __ ]
and trucks but the the lucid dreaming
makes you more aware in your normal
waking life
because you develop
the habit of doing what some people
might call reality checks
and that is asking yourself the question
am i dreaming or am i awake
while you're awake and you would and
then you would test it the way you would
test that for instance
if you had a book cover like this with
text on it in a dream
you looked at the cover at the text you
look away you look
back the text is generally going to
change because your brain is producing
the entire experience moment by moment
so that would be one test be like
looking at text looking away
looking back another would be looking at
patterns like i'm looking at the wall in
front of me
in my kitchen and the tiles are laid a
certain way
if i looked away and looked back at
those tiles they might be running the
opposite direction
or at a diagonal are your dreams that
vivid like my my rem dreams are just
kind of like
i i never really believe that they're
real
do you actually like well if you never
believe they were real you would always
be lucid
right so right but i don't think like
i don't ever remember like picking up a
book and being like oh
it has text on it like that doesn't i
don't get to that high fidelity
like you you work on dream recall first
so you would call
cultivate dream recall and uh
your grasp on the
sort of coattails of details of these
dreams is
is so tenuous that you there are
there's definitely a protocol and an
etiquette
to maximizing dream recall if you don't
do it immediately upon waking you know
if you move around if you brush your
teeth if you go take
a piss like it's gone all of your dreams
are gone you have to be really
methodical and strict about it but
it is incredible how
quickly your dream recall ramps up and
you get to the point where you're
remembering
often times three four five dreams a
night and taking them down
there are ways to improve that you can
wake up in the middle of the night stay
up for two three hours go back to bed i
mean there are all these different
techniques that are outlined in this
book
that really really work so in high
school
when i first became reasonably good at
this i'm not going to say great but i
could usually induce lucidity
in dreams at least every other night and
i was in my final wrestling season
and i would manifest this guy john smith
who was a famous
gold medalist and had a particular type
of wrestling with low leg attacks
i think he was out of oklahoma and i
would train with him
i'd never met him and i never i never
have met him uh
but i would train with him i'd seen a
lot of his video footage and i would
train with him
in my dreams in wrestling and found that
to carry over
into my normal practices so
there are all sorts of things if you're
let's say you have stage fright there
are all sorts of
anecdotes slash case studies of people
who will then
create sort of uh you know
inception style right they'll create the
environment of performing in front of a
crowd they practice this in their dreams
and it gives them an opportunity
to rehearse facing their fears
right so i'm really interested in
lucid dreaming and uh you know there are
some
commonalities between the
uh sort of neurological or
biochemical responses to rem sleep
as compared to the effects produced by
like lsd 25
right there there are some really spooky
similarities
so this this came back to me this is a
book i've
i read many times in late high school
uh certainly early college my own copy
which is covered in highlight
to somewhere and then it was it was just
gifted to me again
so i have many books in my house now
that i would willingly read a second
time
and i think that should be the bar for
reading anything once
it has to be that good that's awesome
yeah that's i i have many books that
i've never touched
you like you have to do but i want to
get to you know it's just like
i i tend to like clean out all the
because like i know you mean
if if anyone that has a podcast that has
more than 10 viewers that you just get
books sent to you like
you get on some publishers list and all
of a sudden like a new book
yeah it's crazy so i tend to to give
those mostly away to friends and whatnot
um cool so uh what else we're gonna
cover today
there was a couple of things i wanted to
hit oh yeah i mean i'd be just i'd be
curious to know what your
how you're thinking about 2021 and what
kind of resolutions you have
if any or how you think about planning
for the new year
yeah i mean i think there was there was
two things
looking i i similar to you and that i
spent
you know a good chunk of time looking
back on the year and and i didn't go
through a calendar but i
i did look at my new year's resolutions
from last year which were
i failed at all of them and so i i just
i mean and i look at what i want to do
differently this year and so i've set up
some procedures in place
and then there were some things some
wins that i did have mid-year but they
weren't resolutions because i didn't
know we were going to be in covit and so
you know i
i think that covid uh what it did for me
is immediately caused me to start
drinking more
it was like very easy to finish a bottle
of wine with my wife like you know
and where you typically be like oh we
have some left over from last night
should we pour a little it's like
no we cleared a bottle out no problem
and then went for a beer or something
you know
it was just like because we were like
we're going to die and it is
so i was i was basically just freaking
out there for the first couple months
um and you know that that kicked off
uh a point to where i got to and i said
i'm fat i feel like i've drank too much
and i need to
course correct and so um if i'm honest
with myself
i i felt really depressed you know not
in a clinical way but in a just this is
really beat me down i miss my friends
i'm miss traveling i miss like
you know there's things that and then
part of me is like well
you know we have clean drinking water we
have food we have jobs like
life is good so but but i think it
it's it's impacted everyone a little bit
differently
and what i immediately went to is said
well how can i stop
and cut back on drinking and then
given that i only have so much free time
with two little girls
what can i introduce that is new
that gives me some relief and brings my
spirits back to
into a positive place and so i tried a
bunch of stuff you know i tried you know
walking through the
the forest because i live in oregon and
we i got a forest in my backyard
tried sauna tried cold plunge meditation
pilates
uh working out lifting weights like all
those things
and i would do a couple weeks of them
and say okay
which one of these if you had to like
stack rank them which ones are having
the biggest impact
on me because i can't do them all which
ones can i do that are having the
biggest impact and
um without a doubt
i would say the two things are
are walking and and and sauna those are
the two things that
that are just so key and um i walk every
single day now
and it is a no phone no earpod
it's like airpods like kind of walk and
it is um it's crazy what 45 minutes in
the forest
will uh will get you in in terms of just
like a mood boost you know like swinging
the arms moving the legs like
it's it's fantastic so so that's been
huge
um also uh in being
totally transparent uh i did some
couples therapy
which i thought was fantastic like and
it's not because i thought i was gonna
in my marriage like i never got that
crazy but it's just something you know
you're cooped up with somebody else
with a couple of like little toddlers
and
it gets chaotic sometimes you know and
it's like you're
there's no work escape work is in the
home like you know there's no
there's no way to have that natural kind
of break that you get
um whether it be grabbing a beer with
another friend and then coming back to
your spouse or like there's none of that
you're just
on top of each other and so um you know
we had done couples therapy back
um uh before and after we got married is
kind of like a
to give us a toolkit to deal with issues
um and it's fantastic i highly recommend
it it's every single time i've done i've
never been
pissed that i did it and you know and
i've always what recommendations would
you give to people
who are listening to this and
considering it as an option
what any best practices or
recommendations for people
well i would say at first i was curious
like are there any new tech plays that i
can get into here like these talk spaces
and some of these other things that are
out there
and i find that those are really kind of
like lightweight
not really meant for couples it was just
like you know texture therapists and i
was like
i don't i don't need this so um
i i found someone that i could actually
meet with over
like a secure zoom type connection that
is a real licensed therapist
not that they aren't on on that but a
dedicated person to you that's going to
give you a full
hour you know um is not not texting back
and forth and
i would say um you know i have another
buddy
that did the same thing and he had to
get to a second therapist to find the
right one so
it's not like just because you find one
that you're
you go to and you're like oh this this
isn't this isn't what i expected
it doesn't mean the the idea of the
practice is wrong you might just not
have the right person
and so we found a fantastic woman that
is
um just really good at
driving me back to the source of why am
i
feeling this way and just opening up the
lines of communication
to let us and remind us that we're both
on the same team
we both want what's best for each other
and to support each other and help each
other because we're coming from a loving
place
but um sometimes we get caught up in in
other things and other
loops and cycles and score keeping i'm a
big score keeper
because i'm i've always avoided
confrontation like my dad was a very
verbally aggressive abusive guy to my
mom and um had many many many good
traits i always like to say that about
my dad because he did
but definitely not teaching me on the
relationship side
um fantastic father uh horrible husband
confusing for me is all hell right as a
kid yeah yeah totally but
um you know i think that uh
i tend to avoid confrontation and then
just kind of keep track of things and
then i then i get upset
and and i have something that that's
like i've all these things ah
you know just come out and so just like
trying to address things in more real
time has been a big
help for me um and
yeah there's been a ton of little things
that i picked up but anyway i just
wanted to tell people out there
if you're going through rough times
because i hear divorce rates are like
through the roof right now
it's like the courts are backlogged it's
it doesn't mean necessarily you found
the wrong person you might just need a
little help and that's okay
yeah i think the real time versus
dropping the mother load of like 17
complaints and yes sort of freeze-framed
infractions
is is really important would you share
that line that you told me that you used
that i think is really helpful
uh which one the one that you oh oh i
think yeah i mean
so i i owe my girlfriend for all of
these because certainly i didn't come up
with these on my own
and i think she's been she is very
conscientious about how she uses
wording and language and you would
expect that i would have that
as as a writer or supposedly
but when i get upset i think i
i i tend to to throw haymakers
right not literally but i'm i'm less
care i'm less
i'm less careful with my wording when
i'm upset
and it it usually escalates
or damages things more than it helps and
i'm not like i'm not a yeller
i never yell but i can be very blunt
and the wording that
uh that she used and i noted it
and i have also used is really simple
it's
it's just the story i
am making up in my head is right and
then you have
that you know you the the dishes are
left in the sink because you expect me
to clean them up
and when i when i believe that thought
i feel x right so you're not disarms it
quite a bit doesn't it
yeah it's really it's
and it's not just being nice
i mean it's being more effective because
as soon as someone is put on the defense
it's game over like you're just not
going to you're not going to get where
you want to go
and by saying and
and this is this is also something if
people wanted to study non-violent
communication
uh i think marshall hey toasty
um i think marshall something or other
you can find it if you just search
marshall
nonviolent communication i can't
remember the last name but there is an
audio course that is quite good
and that's one structure and you would
think as i did i was like well if we're
constantly
both saying the story i'm making up in
my head is that it's going to be so
formulaic that we're going to be like
come on what the [ __ ] you know and it's
just it's not going to work and i have
not found that to be the case it just
continues to be really helpful
even if it is true though that's why
because it is a story you're making up
in your head
right i mean it's always yeah
and having uh
having i you know i i don't know a lot
about couples therapy i have we we have
my girlfriend and i have
worked with people before we're going to
likely
work with someone again just because i
meet
i'm i have phone calls on a weekly basis
with someone who kind of looks after me
uh my girlfriend has phone calls at
least once or twice a week with people
who look after her
but there is no one currently whose
sole priority is to be a
uh sort of midwife even if male
for the relationship right like the the
the cultivator of the relationship us
together
and you know my feeling is even if
they're not
the jedi master of relationship coaches
just having someone who can create
a neutral safe space
where each person can get whatever they
need to get off their chest off their
chest
is a huge service so that it doesn't
bottle up bottle up bottle up
and then explode into this
like 20 exhibit assault
on someone which they just can't easily
recover from they can't easily defend
themselves against
uh and it's really jarring yeah
ultimately for everyone involved uh
and it can force and it can force people
to just kind of throw their hands up and
be like well [ __ ] i don't feel like i
can win here like i just can't win
right i think this has happened a lot
during covid and i know that my
girlfriend and i
have both felt that way at different
points it's like well [ __ ] man
like this is set up in a way like i
don't feel like there's any way i can
win here like there's nothing i can do
that is
is going to lead to me feeling like i'm
being successful
and i think that is much more likely to
happen
when it's bottled up and given out as
like a massive
dosage of 10 or 20 things instead of
like on a weekly basis
having someone else say
well tim like is there anything else on
your mind or anything on your heart that
is that you're withholding right now
and then i'm responding to a question as
opposed to like
snapping over something stupid and then
letting all this stuff fly out of my
face
yeah that's great yeah i think that the
the thing that she's helped me with that
i forgot to mention
is that really just identify who the
cast of characters are
in your head and how they react to
certain situations
because we all have triggers we all have
these little rough patches that if
if you just poke the right way it's
gonna it's gonna
put you in an angry or upset or
frightened or scared
state and um you know
i certainly have those as well and so i
can come at something defensively or
offensively from a place that is one of
these cast of characters
that is taken over my my brain at that
moment
and when you can name them
define them their wants their needs
their fears their hopes
you can say oh that's so-and-so
appearing that has a fear of this
and she's triggering that right now and
so just just
that bringing awareness to that just
like
if you can catch yourself a little bit
it just not that it makes it go away
but you're like oh okay here's who's
making an appearance
i know how to de-escalate this person
this this type of my personality a
little bit better than before
yeah and have a rational conversation
where you actually have an outcome
that is one that is that that puts that
person away for good
right or at least for that that time so
yeah
definitely there's something there's
something it's it's it's not helpful for
everyone
and there are different formats for it
some of it i've found very clunky
um some of it i've found depending on
the facilitator quite helpful for
couples and that is amago therapy
imago people can look it up and
very quickly to decide whether it's
helpful or
not but it it does
help you to convey in a non-violent
non-aggressive way
some of the parts work that you're
referring to
that that certainly for my girlfriend
and i was very
impactful kevin if you had to choose a
word for 2021 for you
like a theme patience patience
yes okay that's something i'm really
trying to cultivate
i feel like you're a pretty patient guy
are you an inpatient guy
well i mean i just think about what we
have ahead of us
in terms of vaccines that who knows when
we're going to get them
you know the crazy scariness of
potential mutations of a virus
new incoming administration the all
things the anxiety and unrest out in the
streets like there's a lot of things
where
i just like i'm very anxious and so i
want things to be
resolved and i want i'm a problem solver
and it's like
i just need to have a little bit more
patience just like slow down
and just let things unfold the way
they're going to unfold and stop trying
to
to to project my mind into the future
into some crazy scenario you know
yeah that's that's a big one for me and
the other thing for 2021 is is just
really asking myself
like the for the drinking thing that
i've i've been really
really good lately um and it i
yeah this is covet drinking so it's like
you know i'm not
going crazy but like it's more than i'd
like to drink so
our our new kind of well my new kind of
um
uh framework that i put together for
myself
has blackouts only on tuesdays tuesdays
no less than 10.
no no no yeah no so
what i'm doing is no more than two i
have found that
uh anything above and beyond two drinks
just does not serve me well
i'm too old i'd wake up like hot in the
middle of the night for no reason
it's the worst so bad hot red white wine
sweats you know
and then the other thing is never never
two nights in a row
so i may say to myself i may be on night
number two and i say
you know like or want to drink the
second night and i just tell myself like
can you go one day oh of course i can
and then you go one day and it turns out
the next day you don't want to drink
and so then it's two nights in a row so
it's funny how just separating drinks by
night will help a ton and then the the
last thing and i think this is the most
important and
the one i don't have a good answer for
but i'm working on this is part of my
my uh um zen friend who's coaching me on
some of this
stuff is really asking yourself
when you're having a drink um
like really who is getting nourished
right now
like that's a good that's a good one
it's a really good one because
what's happening what part of me is is
there something that
because there's there's something inside
that's getting nourished and just trying
to like and i i don't have any answer
for that yet but it's
it's a deep one to sit with you know
yeah i like that
i like that a lot so question for you
when you look at your graph
of drink consumption as it goes down is
your consumption
of edible gummies going through the roof
no it you know also i will tell you i
did try something new called cbn
have you heard of this uh cbn i i have
heard of actually uh from a grower
but i've never consumed so there's a um
here and you should describe describe it
for folks yeah yeah so there's
there's um a a gummy manufacturer out
here and by the way
tim is saying this but you know i am not
like i'm not a big
user of gummies like i'm not oh i'm just
[ __ ] with you but i
do fi i can when when you have had
gummies it is exceptionally clear in our
text messages
it's probably accurate there's probably
pictures of me eating pizza
[ __ ] typing with your elbows yeah
exactly
yes um yeah so
basically uh on the gummy side
there's one a company called wild wild
i they make fantastic
[Music]
yeah and so uh they i think they have
them all on the west coast and they're
starting to spread all over the place
but they do a cbn
it's not really psychoactive but it
really makes you sleep like it is i'm
telling you it's the closest thing i've
had to like
i don't know it just feels like you're
you you took like a sleeping pill or
something like
i take it and it does have a little bit
of thc in there like they do put some
with it
but they but wild makes a sleeping gummy
um so you know for me drinks if
it's it's like especially when i mean
god man the news over the last few weeks
and
months it's just been insane so when
you're stressed out um
and that's the nice thing about a glass
of wine that but a gummy
with with either cbd or cbn but cbn more
so these days
fantastic sleep with it and i wear the
aura ring and i just got the
the fitbit to try out the new sleep data
on here and
um so i'm tracking yeah see how it's
doing
if you have more than two drinks you see
it so clearly in your aura data
it is irrefutable it's just it turns
your sleep into such garbage
it's unreal well resting heart rate goes
up by 10 points
uh and it's elevated all throughout the
night hrv goes down
like there's just so many bad things
that happen yeah
um speaking of which uh in terms of like
awesome little finds that have been
helping us get through these times
this right here i'm gonna send you some
of this tim you gotta try this all right
what is it this is hanoki wood in here
okay and so hinoki wood is one of the
seven
sacred um trees of japan
and when they talk about all the health
benefits that come from forest bathing
in japan because you know uh walking in
the forest can be prescribed out there
from a physician
it's it's typically uh attributed to
a lot of the fragrance from hanoki and
this is hanoki oil right here
i found a fantastic manufacturer in
japan
of high quality like cold pressed hanoki
oil
um and i will tell you what it is i have
zero
i don't know any of these people they're
all in japan uh it is
enoki lab.com
so h-i-n-o-k-i lab.com
these oils they smell so i mean you've
been to like a japanese like
proper bath house where they have like
the essential oils and all
this is the stuff's gold oh and i put it
in the sauna too
so you can put in some water and then
pour it over the coals in the sauna yeah
awesome yeah it's a type of cypress it's
a beautiful beautiful tree really dense
foliage
cool i planted a few of them here in my
yard actually
oh no kidding yeah so i got some i i had
some
uh brought in it's just jesus christ
i love it it's good to be not from japan
no
you have to qualify you brought them in
like i i flew them via freight from
japan
hey man you know almost all the all
those crypt
all that crypto gold i don't know yeah
exactly
i can almost 100 guarantee you that you
have more crypto than i do so if you're
looking to roll
back a place oh jesus christ it's
it's uh yeah well that's not saying much
because you kind of
de-divested yourself yeah
yeah a lot of things for sure i'm
definitely
more i'm scared the markets are just
like super overvalued right now so i i
tend to go safer
yeah yeah i think that's i think there's
there's a good uh
good argument to be made for that if if
i were to pick a word
for 2020 yeah what is it right this
moment
it would be mischievous
i think that i've taken
a lot of things of myself way too
seriously in 2020
and uh i
i think i think i want to bring more
coyote energy
and kind of prankster mischievousness
into 2020. interesting so what does that
look like in you
like like like no mask wearing kind of
thing or no
no that's just being a dick dick face i
don't want to do that
no a coyote it's more yeah it's more
i think a playfulness and
a irreverence
not taking things too seriously uh you
know i'll give you an example
i i just the other day threw up i love
the original willy wonka movie with gene
wilder and
so i threw up this animated gif that
uh is gene wilder sort of eating candy
saying the suspense is terrible i hope
it'll last
and i just threw that up and uh
it was hilarious to see
how people responded and because it's
it's so kind of oblique and
vague that it acts as a rorschach test
for wait a second did you throw this up
like during the trump like
capital takeover today i no i threw i
threw it up right afterwards
oh jeez fuel in the fire dude well you
say
yes i mean you say terrible timing i
think that
i want to cultivate a insensitivity to
uh kind of
personality by consensus what do you
what i mean by that is
if you look at a lot of people i'm not
going to name names but if you yeah
yeah no no i'm not going to cure the
manicured like feeds and stuff
well you just look at personalities
online over time who spend a lot of time
on social
and they become caricatures of
themselves because they have
certain behaviors rewarded certain
behaviors punished
certain behaviors left unapplauded
and they start to warp and bend their
behavior
to fit the most applause and
they turn into these like kind of creepy
caricatures
uh and i think that that i think that
that
ends up inevitably bleeding over into
their
real lives right i mean they're they're
off-screen lives and i think that's
really something i want to be hyper
aware of which is why i don't have the
social on the phone
i'm using these like workarounds like
only paul to post stuff
and i want to kind of hold
up a mirror that allows people to look
at their own reactions
also right so
uh i think that a lot of what i'll put
up
in 2021 will be
uh rorschach tests and for people who
don't know that those are the ink blot
tests where they would put
lots of ink fold a piece of paper show
it to someone and say what do you see
and you know they might see a murderer
they might see a butterfly there might
be something else and then that
is used as kind of a jumping off point
for psychoanalysis
and that's not going to be everything i
put up but i just
think that life is
too short to take yourself too seriously
and so
first and foremost it's for me but
doing things that don't seem to have a
point
uh doing things that are beautiful just
because i think they're beautiful
they don't need to have some targeted
outcome
roi or fill in the blank right
and just to
kind of loosen my grip on
whatever i think my identity is that's
been constructed
over such a long period of time and
let's not kid ourselves
like the like identity can be revealed
but it's largely constructed
right and it's just you i think we get
so attached
to our labels of what we are and what we
aren't what we do and what we don't do
that it's a it's a it's just a
very socially reinforced trap that kind
of constrains
your awareness and sensitivity and
openness to the world
so yeah more coyote that's good i mean
the world needs
i think the problem that we've fallen
into with social media
and part of the reason why i don't like
having an account there is it just
becomes
it's it's really it's it's it makes me
sad in some sense and that i see
it's always the best version of
someone's self like there's never any
like if he feels very very manufactured
oftentimes
and it's it's like it doesn't feel
authentic in the way that
it's always about good times there's
never any like any
i guess there has been more lately with
some of the protests and so the stuff
that's come out on there but
i mean people myself included
tend to put just the best version of
yourself on there
versus just letting it all hang out
which i guess is what kind of what
you're saying in a sense that you're
you're just gonna have more fun with it
than just trying to create the tim
ferriss
like image up on on social media
yeah and you know i don't feel like i've
done
too much of that i mean i i do i've i
very deliberately put out stuff that
is true to me that i think will
uh you know could irritate some
percentage of my
followers just because i i want to have
some countervailing force against
becoming this like dancing sock puppet
on the internet
so i do that to
not become too attached to
social feedback but
you know not to turn this into a
discussion of uh
you know the social dilemma but
if you are constantly exposed to these
technologies like you are completely
outgunned
you're just you're completely outgunned
by
engineers and neuroscientists and
res you know research and development
teams
who have uh for all intents and purposes
infinite resources
to turn you into
so you're just going to keep a little
rat in a skitter box well
yeah i want to i love that the the ai is
going to look at your feet and like
i think tim would like this and like oh
[ __ ] he posted a
yellow pony what what the hell like now
oh damn it like you're really yeah
well i want to keep myself guessing too
right yeah i i don't i love that
yeah follow less of a script and you've
always been good at that though you've
always been like every like one in every
10 of your instagram posts everyone's
like what the hell is he
why is it a picture of that like it's
it's not it's clearly not that
manufactured feed which i've always
appreciated yeah
well i thought was it a camera well
maybe i don't even remember
what it was but back when we were both
on
uh the apps i remember uh one of yours
was like and deleting
in three two one
you to your to your credit sometimes
when i get a little far afield you're
like i think you should probably delete
that
and i'll get a text from you which i
appreciate well i could just tell
well speaking of like you said about my
gummies i can tell when you're a little
ham
too every once while someone will sneak
out there
yeah that's true yeah it's true it's
dangerous dangerous to drink and uh
to drink and post that's a dangerous
habit
uh well it's good to see you man it's
been too long good to see you too
um last little thing i know we always
like to throw a bunch of nuggets out
there for people to
to check out um i i want to recommend a
documentary since we have still so much
time in months ahead of us at home
uh my octopus teacher i thought was
great was great
yes second that cool fantastic
beautifully shot netflix what else you
got
uh i liked uh the last dance the michael
jordan series
it's i know it's a little bit old now
but it was fantastic timeless though
yeah oh my god if you're like yeah i'm a
competitor like okay
watch that watch that exactly
yeah that's i mean one of the best mini
series i've seen in years
uh if you want another documentary which
is actually very uplifting doesn't sound
uplifting uh based on
the name but it's called [ __ ] camp and
it's it begins with the story of a
summer camp for
crippled uh i guess young adults
and one i want to say the grand jury
award at sundance a year or two ago
and it's it's really
outstanding so that's one i would
recommend [ __ ] camp
also tends it just puts a lot in
perspective also
uh so so i i really enjoyed that
uh hamilton's pharmacopoeia just has a
season three coming out now for those
who don't know hamilton morris he's been
on my podcast
uh exceptional biochemist really good at
synthesizing all sorts of things
also a very good storyteller and a
hilarious
hilarious character
unlike any other also happens to be the
son
of errol morris of fog of warfame
and he's a really really
good narrator and editor of the series
called hamilton's pharmacopoeia which
you can find on amazon prime you can
find it on
i want to say vice and season three just
came out and
in each episode he describes
the history of the culture and the
biochemistry of a psychoactive drug
so it could be meth it could be angel
dust it could be lsd it could be
5-meo dmt ketamine ibogaine
and uh in each episode he also then
consumes or administers each of these
drugs
to himself or has them administered and
records the entire experience and
describes the entire experience
so it's uh it's a really well done
series
and that is crazy we'll certainly also
put some fear of god and healthy respect
into the conversations around these
compounds too
yeah not everything turns out well and
although he's usually fine he's very
seasoned
but there are also other people who
agree to have their experiences filmed
and
they don't always turn out fantastically
well that ibogaine stuff man that scares
me
yeah yeah i think i think you should be
very very very very very exceptionally
cautious with ibogaine
and iboga it's one of the few
psychedelics that can
kill you
with cardiac complications
so that that is definitely as far as i'm
concerned
personally off menu although it does
have
some incredible possible applications to
opioid dependence and yeah i've heard
that yeah that's exactly it
yeah there's if you want to see there's
a documentary called dost
d-o-s-e-d i saw early versions of it
which i want to say came out in the last
six to nine months which
which does a good uh showcase
in a sense or exploit provides an
exploration
of specifically opioid addiction and
possible intervention
with uh psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy
thinks of it a along those lines and
ibogaine or iboga i'm not sure which
they used iboga would be the root
i want to say the root bark itself
ibogaine would be the isolated
alkaloid or synthesized depending on how
they approach it
so hamilton's pharmacopia is worth a
gander if you're interested in such
things
uh cool anything else i think that's
it that's all that i have oh no i
have one more uh have you seen the new
um
jazz movie the cartoon ah what am i
drawing
jazz movie no you know what i'm talking
about the cartoon that everyone's
talking about
uh jazz movie i have no idea what you're
talking about like hold on
cut out the extra space on this on the
audio side
hold on i know i want it to be as
awkward as possible no no
jazz cartoon pixar
uh soul soul yes excellent
yes i i wholeheartedly recommend people
check that out
yeah i mean that's really good it's
fantastic i i twisted my friend's arm
into signing up for disney plus
to watch seoul because it's the only
place that i believe you can watch it
that's right and and we watched it and
then i ended up watching the mandalorian
and i was like you know if i had had the
forethought to just use disney plus i
absolutely would have invested in disney
when it got smashed
uh postcoded yeah i mean talk about
the franchises they own it's just marvel
nat geo pixar i mean star wars the
lineup is just
absurd yeah it's crazy so
also a lot of fun yeah uh mandalorian
john favreau congratulations everybody
involved
fantastic show yeah that's a great show
uh and let's see i'll also mention
if you're looking for a healthy snack
i'll mention a company that that i'm
involved with just because i love
their stuff and have had a chance to
spend time
with the co-founders who are husband and
wife
uh jake and uh
muse in in hawaii
who run maui venison oh dude
thank you for the box by the way yeah
you're welcome uh welcome
tim tim sent me a box and i have been i
highly recommend
uh the uh the jerky it's fantastic not
the dog jerky
toaster likes the dog dream i almost
almost broke into that because it was
came with everything else
and i just saw a jerky and i almost went
for it and it looks good enough to eat
but the dog the dog treats are molly's
favorite
the human jerky the bars yeah and
everything are fantastic and the leg
medallions
are just incredible so we haven't eaten
that yet but i'm going to how's the bone
broth by the way because i haven't tried
it yet
bone broth is exceptional it's extremely
high protein
and it's it's it's all outstanding i
mean this is the
as far as i'm concerned and as far as i
can tell the most nutrient
dense meat you can possibly imagine it
is all wild harvested
uh although it's for those people who
might be worried about game harvesting
on public lands it's all done on private
lands on these large ranches
because axis deer in hawaii are
massively damaging as
an invasive species and they actually
not just destroy
the vegetation where it looks so bad
that people
think it's caused by wildfires in that
amount of destruction
but that that leads to erosion and
runoff that also damages the
the coral reef and the marine life uh on
the hawaiian islands
and this is specifically maui so the the
ecological cost is huge and so they work
with usda inspectors they hunt at night
at long range with rifles they only take
head shots to make
the kill as stress-free as possible for
the animals
the entire operation is like something
out of special operations it's
it's unbelievable it sounds like it
they're like night vision and snipers
with head shots yeah they yeah they use
infrared cameras
have you hunted them i have i didn't
know that
i did yeah i hunted with bow uh also
with rifle
but i feel uh
and i don't i don't hunt often but i
i think it is a profoundly
profoundly profoundly impactful way to
reconnect with food
oh dude if you kill an animal and you or
sorry if you
eat an animal but you won't kill it
you're way disconnected from nature
you know what i mean like i've always
told myself i've never killed a cow
but like i do eat cow so if i
if there was a way that i could do it in
a humane fashion
at a place that like i would i would
probably have to do it just because
i'd be i feel like a hypocrite otherwise
oh you shouldn't have said that i'm
going to find you a cow
[Laughter]
i don't want to do it i i don't really
want to do it
at all but i'm just saying that like i
just
i i don't know do you know what i'm
talking about i just i would feel
awkward saying i'm willing to eat you at
someone else's hand
but not not be willing to do it myself
yeah and it's
it's uh you know hunting's not for
everybody i was
i was strongly strongly militantly
anti-hunter
and hunting up until i worked on the
four hours jeff
and i decided for a portion of it that i
wanted to
do my best to learn to hunt and forage
to consume only those things that i
procured myself
and had the opportunity
while doing that deep dive to spend time
with
really hyper intelligent responsible
hunters
like uh stephen ranella who's written
books on the american
bison he's written all sorts of
incredible books on multiple topics
to see that it as far as i'm concerned
can be approached in an extremely
responsible
extremely eco-aware and
thoughtful conscientious manner
uh it really can so the
you know the meat that i have here and
the meat that i ate when i was
when i was hunting in hawaii was from
what we got that day
yeah and and i feel very good about that
yeah i mean that's very good about it
that's the
that's the the evil side of hunting
obviously is both on the
species that that are in low numbers
which obviously is just a
massive no-no and then also the for the
trophy of it
you know like like i l i i really
respect the people that have learned
how to do the full you know nose-to-tail
processing
of an animal and to make use of of
everything they possibly can it's it's
really
it's really quite cool yeah so so people
interested
check out the video on
mauinwivenison.com
the video is incredibly well done it's
done with award-winning cinematographer
uh and it shows the kind of ethos and
mission and how they approach all this
stuff
it's incredible uh so maui
m-a-u-i-nui n-u-i-venison.com and people
can check it out it's
it is the startup and and you know kevin
i've made basically no
direct startup investments in the last
handful of years
and i've been helping these guys it's a
very tough business
it's the best product in the world as
far as i'm concerned
uh and i i'm so enamored
of this company and the family and the
people behind it and the ethos it's just
like it checks all the boxes for me so
it's awesome
food investing is hilarious to me by the
way because like i would say on tech
fantastic track record then the cricket
protein
remember you did those cars but the
funny thing about that is then they went
and started a new company
yeah that's killing it healing it magic
spoon is killing it and yeah
you unfortunately missed out on that one
i did i did miss but
you know it's it's uh i'm doing okay
with food man
i'm doing actually uh that's the only
two investments i know you have so maybe
you have a handful
well blue bottle did follow there you go
both of us that's right blue
blue bottle did fantastically well and
uh
hugh the chocolate makers were just
acquired i think the announcement was
last week by mondelez
and i was an advisor to uh well i
suppose i still am an advisor to you so
that was also
that's a really uh fantastic
i'm just giving you [ __ ] i mean like
literally 90 of the deals that we do
like go to zero then that's totally fine
that's the name of the game on on the
early stage investing
yeah but if i could if i could choose
one that i really want
to not just survive but thrive like maui
would be at the very top of the list
just because the
the sort of benefits to community and
ecology
and like the way that they're walking
the talk
in a beautiful philosophical sense
is just it's rare it's super super rare
that's awesome i will say that um
in with the product that i have tried so
far i haven't tried it all
uh if you're scared of the idea of
venison you shouldn't be because it's
very damn tasty jerky like you would you
would it's not
gaming at all it's um and then i will
say
uh magic spoon for people that are like
old-school cereal like fruity loops but
want a keto friendly snack
do you say fruity loops you 90 year old
no they have like fruity loops like
flavor type
oops
[Laughter]
yeah you know what fruity fruity leaves
was the dj software do you remember that
now you can make it was like he made
loops it was something like that okay
i got it yeah so magic spoon i mean
i have an entire pantry full of their
stuff and i'm really
thrilled for the founders they've done
an extremely good job of making a great
product
so yeah if you if you liked cocoa puffs
froot loops
these types of cereals as a kid you can
have
cereal that tastes very much the same
that is
basically zero carbs super low net carb
with high protein and enjoy it with your
real milk or fake milk
of choice and it it's fantastic
my favorite is the chocolate i really
like the chocolate flavor yeah the
chocolate
they had one two that was like a
cinnamon one that was quite good
um anyway yeah good stuff cool magic
spin
coolio coolio man well uh do you want to
tell people where they can find you
yeah i mean eventually this year i'm
going to start up on the instagram again
that's probably the best place i'm just
at kevin
rose um you can find me there
and i also have a podcast that i put out
one episode about every three months
it's not that regular but i do have
really good guests i just had
some great ones i had andy ratcliffe on
um most recently
who's um founder of benchmark um and
also wealthfront
um benchmark capital being one of the
most successful venture capital firms of
all time
um and fantastic interview about the
importance of a diversification
and um yeah just like it's
he's a brilliant brilliant man have you
ever had andy on your show
you know i have but i had it via mike
maples show and she did an episode where
andy
was featured and so we published that
audio
on my chest yeah smart guy extremely
smart guy i wish he would write a book
man he's one of those guys
you could just sit down and talk to and
everything that you throw at him he has
a different take on and most the time
he's right
and you're just like this needs to be
some like you know how ray dalio put out
his principles book
like yeah andy needs his version of that
you know it's like
yeah so one could dream i tried to talk
him he wouldn't do it
he said he doesn't want to do it books
books are a pain in the ass but he could
get a ghostwriter
collaborator and that person would just
interview him like a few hours a day for
a week straight and then they would have
all they needed so there we go andy if
you're listening make it happen
all right kev kev well it's uh lovely to
see you
yeah good to see you as well let's hang
in in person this year man let's make it
happen
let's make it work long road trip i'll
get in my armored marauder vehicle
and make my way across country to visit
you in the forest
maybe that's the next move do some
forest bathing together
it just means walking in the forest that
sounds sounds exotic and erotic i can't
wait
i mean we've done some of that in japan
that's true
we need to get back to japan that would
be fun man well step by step let's
figure out domestic travel first and
then
figure out japan fair enough yeah all
right absolutely
not okay man well to be continued
and um much love to you and the family
my man
same to you and uh everyone out there
please stay safe
and healthy and take care of yourselves
bye-bye
you